let's now consider our rolling wheel and
we want to look at some special
conditions so at time T equals zero and
we'll have our wheel that's rolling
here's the ground let's say that our
point P is right up here at the top
that's CM and we'll be in the ground
frame now and then at a later time time
T the wheel has moved to the right so
let's draw the wheel over here not the
greatest picture of the wheel but we'll
have the wheel over here and now the
point P has moved some angle Delta Theta
and we'll call this time interval delta
T now the center of mass of the wheel
has moved a distance x cm is the
velocity of the center of mass times
delta T and the point P on the rim this
art changed this length here on the rim
that p is moved around in the center of
mass frame is R Delta Theta
now we want to ask ourselves we'll call
this Delta X we now have three possible
conditions we call rolling without
slipping that will be our first case one
and that's the case when the arc length
Delta s is exactly equal to the distance
along the ground so we have Delta X cm
is Delta s and so we get V cm delta T
equals R Delta Theta or B cm equals R
Delta Theta over delta T now in the
limit as delta T goes to zero we have
that Delta Theta over delta T in this
limit as delta T goes to zero is d theta
DT and that's what we called the angular
speed so in our limit for as this wheel
is rolling without slipping we have the
condition that the velocity D cm equals
R Omega so that's our first condition
and we call this the rolling without
slipping now what is V cm that's the
velocity of the center of mass of the
wheel and every single point on this
wheel has that same speed and R Omega
you can think of that as the tangential
velocity in reference frame CM this is
just the speed in the reference frame
moving with the center of mass so this
is our condition for rolling without
slipping
now if the wheel our second case is
imagine that the ground that the wheel
is not moving forward at all but it's
just spinning that's what we call the
wheel
is slipping on the ground for instance
if there were ice and so what we call
slipping is a little bit more general
it's whenever the wheel is spinning and
the arc length is much greater than the
horizontal distance that the wheel is
moved so we have Delta s representing
the arc length that the point is moved
in the center-of-mass frame is greater
than how far the center of mass is
moving and so again we have our Delta
Theta is greater than B cm delta T or in
the limit our Omega is greater than V cm
you can say it's spinning faster than
its translating and finally the skidding
condition skidding imagine that the
wheel you're breaking a wheel the wheel
is not spinning at all but it's just
sliding along horizontally so the
horizontal Delta X center of mass is
bigger than Delta s cm and so this is
the case where Delta X cm how far it
moved horizontally is greater than the
amount of arc length that that point
moved and so in the same type of
argument when we put our conditions in
we get that the CM is greater than R
Omega and again with that corresponds to
in the skidding case imagine the limit
where it's not rotating at all this
would be zero and it's just skidding
along the ground BCM so we have our
three conditions we have the slipping
condition where it's spinning faster
than its translating we have the
skidding condition where it's
translating faster than its spinning and
we have the rolling without slipping
condition in which the arc length is
exactly equal to the distance horizontal
distance along the ground